генерале ходжис сьогодні увага світу
прикута до Ізраїлю та сектору гази армія
оборони Ізраїлю заявляє що готується до
наступного етапу війни якщо розпочнеться
довгоочікувана наземна операція у чому
полягатиме основний
ризик Я думаю для армії оборони Ізраїлю
є три істотні ризики перший і найбільш
очевидний увійти до гази буде дуже
непросто Я маю на увазі бойові дії
всередині міста особливо коли хамас
чекає на них і навіть хоче щоб вони туди
увійшли думаю що військові Ізраїлю
розуміють що це буде дуже важко плюс
величезний тиск щодо мінімізації жертв
серед цивільного населення Тому що весь
світ спостерігає президент США дуже ясно
дав зрозуміти прем'єр-міністру нетаньяху
що США очікують від ізраїльських
військових дотримання всіх законів
збройного
конфлікту що не просто для молодого
офіцера чи солдата з одного боку
адвокати та журналісти які за всім
стежать а з іншого хамас який
намагається вас вбити Так що це буде
складно але армія оборони Ізраїлю
ймовірна найкращо у світі з точки зору
підготовки та оснащення для виконання
таких місій Вони знають що на них чекає
друга Велика небезпека полягає в тому що
якщо Іран відкриє Другий фронт і хезбела
атакуватиме з Лівану щоб ще більше
відвернути увагу на західному березі то
Ізраїлю доведеться відбивати інші атаки
з інших місць Я впевнений що так буде
Я просто не знаю наскільки значними
будуть ці атаки але вони чекатимуть поки
цахал закріпиться всередині міста третя
проблема в який момент зупинитися у чому
суть місії ймовірно щоб знищити хамас і
зробити газу непридатною для його
функціонування чи треба для цього
ізраїльським солдатам перебувати там
місяцями гарантувати безпеку окупувати
Це буде дуже важко тому прояснити цілі
операції на мою думку дуже важливо
у разі початку наземної операції схоже
існує ризик великої кількості жертв
серед мирного палестинського населення
багато ізраїльських заручників можуть
вбити чи є якісь альтернативи наземній
операції звісно завжди є альтернатива
Але чи буде вона прийнятною На мою думку
буде зроблено все можливе щоб урятувати
якнайбільше заручників хамас розуміє що
живі заручники набагато цінніші ніж
мертві тож заручники безперечно
залишаються у Великій небезпеці але
хамасу вони потрібні бо там розуміють
наскільки для ізраїльтян важливо
повернути цих людей І звісно там є
чимало американців та громадян інших
країн тож усе це треба врахувати щодо
альтернатив то я думаю Ізраїль ще не
розпочав наземну операцію тому що його
поки що не влаштовують умови вони ще не
знищили достатньо керівників хамасу та
його інфраструктуру за допомогою авіації
або Вони все ще займаються тим що ми
називаємо розвідувальною підготовкою для
кращого розуміння де ворог де цивільні
особи де Тунелі це важливий етап але
довго зволікати не можна бо призвано 300
000 резервістів ці люди відірвані від
роботи І колись це почне даватися в
знаки хамас звісно використовує цей час
для покращення своєї оборони але
ізраїльтяни також використовують цей час
для практики тренувань підготовки Я
думаю армія оборони Ізраїлю розпочне
операцію коли буде створено необхідні
умови але я уявляю який чиниться тиск з
боку США та інших держав які безумовно
розуміють бажання Ізраїлю знищити хамас
але також співчувають і тяжкому
становищу палестинського народу який
опинився у пастці Я вважаю Всі хотіли б
врегулювати конфлікт і стати на шлях
розв'язання проблеми шлях співіснування
двох
держав Як би ви описали можливості
цахалу чи спроможний він воювати на
кілька фронтів якщо в конфлікт вступить
хезбола чи навіть
Іран у них дуже значний військовий
потенціал постійний склад понад 150 000
Плюс зараз призвано понад 300 000
резервістів варто відзначити що вони
призвали 300 000 а прийш 360 000 Люди
навіть поверталися зі США щоб піти на
службу вочевидь у них найкраща у світі
система ППО залізний купол принаймні
найкраща для виконання поставлених
завдань Таким чином з точки зору їхньої
здатності справлятися з численними
загрозами Я впевнений що це їм під силу
але в якийсь момент вони можуть захотіти
проникнути глибше до Ірану Сирії або
інших місць щоб наприклад завадити
іранцям постачати дедалі більше
боєприпасів тож приводом для
занепокоєння стане вихід конфлікту за
межі Ізраїлю та
гази США на тлі чимраз вищого ризику
ескалації нарощують свої сили у регіоні
чи може Америка бути втягнута у
масштабнішу регіональну
війну я не думаю що це можливо Іран
наврядчи хоче щоб американський флот чи
інші сили знищили те що він має думаю
міністру оборони США варто було б
розгорнути дві ударні групи авіаносців у
Східному середземно морі для стримування
і щоб донести до тегерана що це не Блеф
що ми готові І що в регіон вводиться
більше сил для протиповітряної та
протиракетної оборони але звісно і на
випадок непередбачуваних обставин якщо
доведеться евакуювати цивільних осіб те
що ми називаємо невоєнною операцією з
евакуації інші країни будуть зацікавлені
в тому щоб бути готовими до такого
сценарію тож навряд чи ескалація можлива
На мою думку Влада Ірану замислиться над
тим як далеко вона зможе зайти щодо
втягування США у конфлікт то на мою
думку наші президент і міністр оборони
будуть дуже обережними ми вже бачили як
хусити запустили ракети і американський
Корабель карні зміг їх збити думаю
ймовірно подібні інциденти будуть
траплятися але ніхто не зацікавлений у
тому щоб ми були безпосередньо
залучені
американські війська в регіоні були
атаковані безпілотниками кілька разів чи
готові США до такої
війни Так я припустив би що можливості
для захисту військ на різних базах у
регіоні від безпілотників є і їх
створюється все більше але коли ви маєте
справу з терористичними організаціями
які готові запустити ракети будь-якої
миті це створює постійну
[музика]
небезпеку
У той час як увага всього світу прикута
до Близького Сходу війна в Україні
триває чи могли б США особливо
напередодні президентських виборів
надавати військову підтримку Ізраїлю та
продовжувати свою військову допомогу
Україні безперечно це сказав днями і
президент Байден коли йому поставили те
саме питання він сказав це Сполучені
Штати звісно ми можемо і
продовжуватимемо підтримувати Україну
якій треба перемогти Росію тому що
китайці спостерігають чи серйозно Ми
ставимося до всього того що поставлено
на карту весь міжнародний порядок
заснований на правилах поваги до
суверенітету прав людини повага до
свободи судноплавства повага до
міжнародних угод китайці хочуть побачити
чи справді ми серйозно ставимося до
цього тож ця позиція незмінна і звісно у
сполучені Штати дуже ясно дали зрозуміти
що ми збираємося допомогти Ізраїлю
захистити себе особливо від тієї
терористичної організації знищення якої
ми б теж хотіли але я думаю і дякую вам
за це питання що це не окремі інциденти
головним бенефіціаром цього є Росія
Кремль хоче щоб усі ми відвели свою
увагу та ресурси від України після 7
жовтня вам напевно важко знайти статті
на перших шпальтах про Україну через те
що відбувається в і
знову ж таки я не думаю що це
випадковість Я вважаю Кремль зі своїм
найближчим союзником іраном керує всім
цим я не думаю що є аркуш паперу на
якому написано ми хочемо щоб ви
атакували в такий-то день але очевидно
що вони працювали разом протягом
багатьох років і особливо в Останні
кілька місяців вони допомагають один
одному ресурсами зброєю а хезбула та
хамас не можуть зробити нічого суттєвого
без ресурсів підтримки та керівництва
татегерана тому я думаю як сказав наш
президент ми маємо розв'язувати цю
проблему комплексно я маю на увазі що ми
захід маємо організуватись об'єднати
наші союзи та коаліції змусити нашу
оборону промисловість знову працювати І
звертаючись до нації нещодавно президент
згадав Другу світову війну коли захід
усвідомив загрози що походять з різних
місць ми організувалися наша
промисловість організувалася і тоді
звісно економічний потенціал та збройні
сили привели до успіху і я думаю що саме
Так ми і зробимо Ми переможемо хамас
допомагаючи Україні перемогти Росію яка
більше не може допомогти Ірану Ось як ми
це робимо і це також стримуватиме
Китай Але чи вважаєте ви що Росія грала
активну роль у цьому конфлікті чи просто
заохочувала
Іран Я б сказав набагато більш ніж
заохочувала я не знаю чи постачали вони
щось адже справи Росії настільки Гані що
їй доводиться імпортувати боєприпаси з
Північної Кореї вони імпортують
безпілотники з Ірану Але в цьому
крутяться великі гроші і є чимало
чинників які могли підштовхнути Іран
тому я на 100% упевнений що це
скоординовані зусилля Ірану та
Росії Дякую вам
дякую